Chris Brown spills all the details about the night he attacked Rihanna in his new documentary Chris Brown welcome to my life the 28 year old R&B singer opens up about the events that led to the altercation with Rihanna prior to the 2009 Grammy Awards explaining they were never the same after he admitted to sleeping with another woman early on in their relationship things escalated when said woman approached him at the Clive Davis party the night before the Grammys here's how chris says things went down after they left in his Lamborghini so did she gives me a couple more times and I just kind of just it doesn't go from translation to sit down I'm telling you the truth it goes so now I'm finna be mean she try to keep me he's like just her just being upset but then already hit him like I punched him busted her lip and when I saw it I was in shock Chris was charged with felony assault for attacking Rihanna he pleaded guilty I hate it to this day you know Jaime